T
TONIGHT PRETTY WELL IN THE BIG
STATES.
>> KARL?
>> IF YOU ADD UP THE NUMBER OF
SEATS IN WHICH REPUBLICANS ARE
LEAVING THE REST OF THE COUNTRY
AND CALLED BY SOMEBODY COMING
THEY GET YOU ABOUT 222, WHICH IS
EXACTLY WHAT THE DEMOCRATS HAVE
TODAY.
>> A FIVE SEAT OF MAJORITY.
>> WE ARE LIKELY TO FIND
OURSELVES IN A PLACE GOVERNING
FROM THE REPUBLICAN SIDE, BUT
THE DIFFERENCES TRYING TO
TRANSFORM AMERICA WITH PASSING
LEGISLATION SIGNED BY THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
>> DANA?
>> I WOULD SAY BOTH SIDES YOU
HAVE FRIENDS WHO POSSIBLY COULD
NOT BELIEVE THAT ANYBODY WHO HAS
ANY SENSE WOULD EVER VOTE FOR A
DEMOCRAT.
AND YOU WILL HAVE DEMOCRATS WHO
SAY, "I CAN'T LEAVE ANYBODY WITH
ANY COMPASS WOULD VOTE FOR A
REPUBLICAN."
THE TWO SIDES ARE TOO FAR APART
AND HAVE A LITTLE BIT OF GRACE
AND UNDERSTANDING AND TRY TO
LEGAL BIT INTO THESE RESULTS AND
WHAT PEOPLE ARE THINKING BECAUSE
AMERICA DOES FEEL LIKE THERE IS
NO ORDER, A LINE BILL HEMMER HAS
COINED.
>> TWO CONCEPTS COME I THINK
VOTERS WANT A MORE POPULOUS
CONSERVATIVE AGENDA AS KELLY
INDICATED BUT I THINK THEY ARE
ALSO TIRED OF CHAOS.
THEY WANT NORMALCY.
I THINK A LOT OF THESE
CANDIDATES SEEMED MORE CHAOTIC
THAN NORMAL.
I THINK THAT HURT REPUBLICANS IN
A MAJOR WEIGHT ALL ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
>> BILL HEMMER, GREAT JOB ON THE
BOARD APPEARED >> FANTASTIC.
>> THE BATTERIES ARE STILL
WORKING.
[LAUGHTER]
>> BUT WE ARE GOING TO STOP,
RIGHT?
>> FINAL THOUGHT?
>> I THINK WHAT YOU'RE SAYING
AND WISCONSIN WILL HOLD UP.